bevor dieses video losgeht habt ihr denn
auch schon meine rost yourself challenge
also mein neues musikvideo gesehen
checkt es auf jeden fall mal ablegen
ganz oben in der video beschreibung und
lasst eure meinung da ist viel spaß mit
dem video etwas glaubt jetzt willkommen
beim neuen video
ja ich habe mich heute natürlich mal
wieder was ganz besonderes überlegt und
zwar hab ich auch richtig bock dieses
video grad zu drehen
ich bin nämlich gerade hergegangen und
ungefähr vor ein zwei wochen kann man
das video von mir
womit jungs mädchen zeigen dass sie
nichts von ihnen wollen und da hab ich
euch wieder aufgefordert die jungs und
mädels schreibt mir noch einmal weitere
jungs mädchen themen die ihr gerne von
mir sehen wollte in die kommentare
und ich dachte das zu bekommen dann
suchst du dir auch mal stellen neues
thema raus gehe auf das video lässt die
kommentare waren auch wirklich viele
also so ist es gar nicht erst schreibt
jeder like wenn du atmest von luki time
1000 likes das ist echt super
das hilft mir weiter mit solchen
kommentaren kann man arbeiten leute das
ist der überschritt man so was brauche
ich dann habe ich einfach mal ein
bisschen herunter gerollt und disco dann
habe ich einfach mal ein bisschen weiter
runter gescrollt warten jetzt dieser
moment wenn du jeden abend zu lange wach
bleibt es jeden morgen bereist und es
jeden tag wiederholt auch ein toller
kommentar mit fast 600 likes oder so er
jungs ihr seid super spitze man euch
brauche ich aber dann kam der moment wo
ich wirklich diesen einen kommentar
gefunden habe nachdem ich gesucht habe
ich habe euch aufgefordert was wollt ihr
noch sehen und das kann doch nicht so
schwer sein die julia schreibt könntest
du ein video darüber machen wo man merkt
ob der typ nur freundschaft oder mehr
will und wie man friends on vermeiden
kann 527 likes dankeschön julia du hast
mir wirklich geholfen
mach weiter so was wie dich brauche ich
und nicht so ein rätsel wie atmen oder
sowas wo ich muss dann erst mal googeln
was friends on heißt weil ich mit dem
wort nicht so viel anfangen konnte
aber jetzt weiß ich es frenzel ist wenn
das war dass wenn man also leute fast
auf frenzel ist wenn ihr als mädchen
deinem besten freund oder als junge eine
beste freundin und sich einer von den
beiden
mehr wünscht als nur freundschaft glaube
ich und ich weiß zugenommen aber ihr
habt ja wahrscheinlich am titel auch
schon gelesen es geht heute um anzeichen
dass er mehr als freundschaft wird man
kann es vielleicht auch anzeichen dass
sie mehr als freundschafts wilhelm ich
habe wirklich überlegt ob ich mich
einfach nennen kann anzeichen dass er
schrägstrich sie mehr als freundschaft
will also sofort auch mädchen auch
übertragen
aber ich glaube da gibt es ein paar
unterschiede und die könnt ihr mal als
mädchen in die kommentare schreiben wenn
ihr bock habt an sonst würde ich sagen
es geht los mit diesem video und jetzt
geht's los ich habe mich hingesetzt habe
ein paar punkte ausgearbeitet und wir
fangen an mit pop nummer eins und zwar
ist das eigentlich ganz einfach da bin
ich wirklich sofort drauf gekommen und
zwar wenn ein junge zum beispiel herzen
besten freuen und wirst dich so ist das
mein bester freundin oder will er
irgendwie mehr an unter freunden ist es
ja irgendwie so manchmal so
selbstverständlich dass zum beispiel
jetzt mal der alles zahlt oder der alles
zahlt aber bin ja einen besten freund
hat und zusammen mit dem essen gilt oder
keine ahnung was macht und der wichtig
immer darauf besteht wegen immer dass er
alles zahlt dann habt ihr einerseits
vielleicht mehr glück und er hat so viel
geld
andererseits könnte es aber vielleicht
auch ein anzeichen dafür sein dass er
was wollen wir
andererseits können das aber eventuell
auch ein anzeichen dafür sein dass er so
mehr von euch will und deswegen so denkt
damit zeigt er ich bin cool so wisst ihr
klingt für mich auf jeden fall sehr
logisch und ich glaube ich würde es auch
so machen deswegen hab ich ein punkt mit
reingenommen wir machen weiter mit pop
nummer zwei und zwar ihr müsst ihr
darauf achten wenn es eigentlich euer
bester freund ist aber er nie von
irgendwelchen anderen mädchen erzählte
von seiner ex freundin oder ex ex freund
oder ex ex freund oder xxl xxxl
da wirst du sofort was ich meine ist ja
auch logisch ich meine wenn ihr das ist
ja ein zeichen dafür so ja ist ja
irgendwie selbst erklären ich mein
welcher junge rede vor seiner freundin
über seine ex freundin
außer man sucht stress dann ist es eine
gute option wir weiter mit
punkt nummer drei ich wollte eigentlich
nur so machen aber das passt voll und
zwar müsst ihr einfach mal als mädchen
darauf achten wie er sich so im realen
leben euch gegenüber verhält und wie es
dann ist wenn ihr so schreibe weil es
gibt natürlich auch eine menge jungs die
einfach schüchtern sind und dann
vielleicht so denn wenn man schreibt so
voll aus sich herauskommt und halt dinge
schreiben die sie so im realen leben nie
sagen und wenn ihr dann wirklich
manchmal so denkt so hey was schreibt er
da
dann könnte das auch eventuell ein
anzeichen dafür sein dass er so kommen
du bist doch ganz gut und ich würde dich
gern mal richtig durch anderem das nicht
okay wir machen weiter und zwar wenn ihr
einen besten freund habt und denkt schon
so 11 12 13 jahre alt seid also ich
finde so 12 13 sollte man heutzutage
schon sein
und der beste freund wirklich kümmern
mit euch saufen will weil ich mein das
geht ja heute schon mit 11 12 13 jahren
los ist ja völlig normal ich meine auf
den flaschen steht ja nicht ab 16
ein schlingel okay mir spaß als ihr
seiten schon 15 mindestens 15 sag ich
jetzt mal und euer bester freund wir
wirklich immer mit euch laufen dann ist
das vielleicht auch ein zeichen dafür
dass er sich durch diesen alkoholkonsum
mehr erhofft beziehungsweise dass er aus
sich herauskommt und dass ihr es euch
heraus kommt vielleicht ist ja auch
einfach nur alkoholabhängig aber glaub
ich nicht okay das soll jetzt nicht
falsch verstehen also ich will euch
nicht dazu überreden alkohol zu trinken
aber das könnte ich glaube ich schon so
ein anzeichen sein wenn das so wirklich
immer passiert so kommen wir machen
einfach schnell weiter dann muss ich
dazu nicht mehr so viel sagen auf jeden
fall kommen wir zum letzten punkt und
zwar ihr habt einen besten freund und
der schreib ich meine es kann ja auch
nett sein so wenn man sich als noch bei
den mädchen oder bei ihrer besten
freundin man als junger so ab und zu mal
melden zum vielleicht ein zweimal die
woche um 1 uhr noch schreibt so ja alles
cool langeweile aber
wenn man das dann wirklich so jeden tag
schreibt um ein uhr nachts das ist ein
punkt den man so und so sehen aber ich
würde sagen also wenn ihr als mädchen
wirklich mal so voll spätabends
nachricht von dem gleichen jungen
bekommt ist das vielleicht ein zeichen
in die richtung so hier komm ich finde
ich ganz attraktiv und genau die leute
das war's mit meinem neuen video ich
hoffe natürlich erst hat euch gefallen
wenn ihr aber lass mal nach oben da ich
hab die letzten mal schon gesagt ich
glaube ein 12.000 jetzt kommt das
nächste jungs mädchen wie du
schreibt doch dieses mal auf jeden fall
auch wieder in die kommentare was ihr
sehen wollt oder was zum thema ich halt
besprechen soll
und bleibt dann die kommentare die euch
gefallen und dann sehen wir uns bestimmt
schon nicht sogar übernächste woche
wieder mit so einem video jetzt zeigt
auf jeden fall noch meine rost yourself
challenge also mein neues musikvideo das
kam letzten irgendein online ist hier
noch irgendwo verlinkt oder in der video
beschreibung check das abbild mich
freuen und dass eure meinung darunter in
den kommentaren da interessiert mich
sehr ansonsten sehen wir uns morgen 19
uhr live video haut rein ich habe euch
lieb und ihr mich auch hoffe ich weiß
ich nicht